[Music]
do you use hashicorp vault for secrets
management and to define policy as code
and need to deploy a scalable
certificate authority
thanks to an open source backend plugin
you can get these two critical security
tools playing well together
continue your policy as code practice
and keep the same tooling and i'm going
to show you how google's certificate
authority service cas simplifies private
certificate management and runs at scale
if you already use hashicorp vault to
define your certificate policies as code
it can be hard to switch to using the
native cas certificate issuance controls
so you'll need a way to connect the two
and you're in luck because we have a
proxy solution
by adding a plugin for vault you can
instruct it to act as a proxy issuing
certificates through google's cas backed
by vault secured secrets
it works by generating a private key and
certificate signing request or getting
the request from a user to deliver
certificates through vault with cis
issuing them behind the scenes
the plugin can't create or delete any
certificate authorities or manage any
other parts of the life cycle it just
allows you to connect vault to cas so
you can natively issue certificates
without rewriting your services
the github repo linked below has more
detailed instructions for how to set up
the plugin and get all of the pieces
connected
once you have hashicorp vault already
installed and a ca setup on cas you're
ready to deploy the plugin code the
plugin code is open source and if needed
can be forked and be self-maintained or
you can send prs to google cloud for
maintenance
you'll need to have a user or service
account that vault uses and allow it to
generate and revoke certificates
we recommend using custom iam roles here
to give the vault service account the
minimal set of permissions required
which would include create and update
for the private ca dot certificates
permission set there's a link in the
description for how to create custom
roles
once you've set up the plugin you can
now let your administrators take
advantage of the existing workflows and
access controls within vault to control
certificate permissions
you also enjoy the flexibility of
defining who can request certifications
and what limits to place on the
certificates themselves
if you're using vault and want to try
cas check out the plugin on github read
through the detailed readme there and
let us know how we can further improve
it
[Music]